hey everyone and welcome back
surprisingly we've managed to make it
through four weeks of this series so far
which is pretty impressive because after
I finish I am looking forward to getting
started on my next series lifting and
Lead code where I max out on bench and
then proceed to superet that with a lead
code problem so uh yeah we'll see if we
ever get to that one uh but anyways
today we'll be talking about Facebook
Messenger so let's go ahead and get into
it all righty so as we mentioned today
we are going to be building both
Facebook Messenger or Whatsapp which are
effectively the same thing I think the
one difference being that Facebook
Messenger actually stores your messages
uh internally in some database whereas
WhatsApp caches everything locally on a
device don't quote me on that I'm
American so I don't really use WhatsApp
very much but uhu as far as I understand
it that's the main difference I'm going
to treat them like they're the same
thing but anyways here's what an app
like that might look like as you can see
on the left side of the screen we've got
a bunch of different chats for example
the ladies Donald Trump Elon Musk Tech
lead I can select one of them and I can
show it off so this would be the chat
with the link ladies over here as you
can see we've got Kate Upton inviting me
over got Anna dearmas letting me know
that she loves Fang engineers and then
of course myself who is too busy to come
over because I'm making systems design
videos on my YouTube channel by the way
this is a very accurate representation
of how my interactions with women go in
real life so uh just wanted to put that
out there so let's go through some
formal problem requirements so we can
actually move into the design in a
little bit so for one the one thing that
we definitely need to be able to do is
support chats so in particular let's
imagine that we can support group chats
with up to 10 users I don't think that's
too infeasible of a requirement you know
you could say 100 users I think in
reality iMessage supports up to like 32
so I feel like 10 is the same order of
magnitude and that should be reasonable
enough we need to be able to send
messages as a user we need to be able to
receive them on our client devices in
real time on every single open client
device and then we also should be able
to persist these messages in some sort
of database table so that if I were to
log in on a new device I can go ahead
and access those historical messages and
of course load older
conversations so let us get into some
capacity estimates so that we can get a
sense of how much scale we're going to
need to build for let's imagine that
we've got around a billion total users
that's not actually that unreasonable
considering that's about an eighth of
the globe and that's about probably how
many users Facebook has if each user
sends around 100 messages a day which I
also think is pretty reasonable if each
message is around 100 bytes including
the metadata which again if a message is
you know let's say like 20 characters on
average or maybe 50 characters on
average when we include the metadata
that probably puts us around 100 bytes
so multiplying those three numbers
together we can see that we'll store
around 10 terabytes of data per day and
multiplying that by around 365 or let's
round it to 400 that's about 4 pedabytes
per year so a lot of data but at the
same time if you're a massive company
that makes a lot of money like Facebook
you can go ahead and afford storing that
much you're just going to have to do
some
partitioning okay so the first thing
that I'm going to do in order to kind of
introduce the data models that we're
using is touch upon a couple of key data
structures or database schemas that
we're going to need and then from there
we can actually talk about the sending
and receiving of messages within a group
chat so the first data table that I'm
going to talk about or database that I'm
going to talk about is the chat members
table so basically the idea here is that
when we have a chat we need to be able
to know and especially for a given user
what chats that us answer is in that's
very important for that kind of left
part of this view over here I need to be
able to query and figure out what chats
I'm actually in so I can build this
section so an easy way to make sure that
we can do that and do it quickly such
that the query returns fast is by making
a data table that looks something like
this we've got our user ID on the left
our chat ID on the right and as long as
we index and Partition by that user ID
we can ensure that not only are results
sorted in the order that we want but
also that basically we can ensure that
all of our queries to find all of my
chats for example would be on a single
database partition that is going to be
very nice now you may think to yourself
well what if we want to increase the
right through put for a table like this
what if I'm constantly joining new group
chats I mean for starters I don't really
think that would happen that often and
that's why I ultimately assume the
database is not going to be a
performance bottleneck but let's imagine
as just a thought experiment that we
really did need some great performance
on this one well what we could do is
employ something like a leaderless
replication schema for our database the
issue with that is that what if on one
node right I basically say join group
chat and then on this guy over here
which has yet to synchronize with the
first leader I go ahead and say leave
group
chat and then these guys eventually sync
together somehow and then it's kind of
arbitrary which message message is
actually going to win so I may end up
either being in that group chat or not
being in that group chat and that could
be bad for example you know if it's not
me writing join group chat or leave
group chat and it's someone else doing
it on my behalf maybe they wanted to
kick me out of the group chat and now
all of a sudden I'm still in there and
they can see me talking about them
so at the end of the day uh probably is
important to have a single leader if we
want to maintain causal dependencies
that being said the one possible
solution we could use for a leaderless
database schema would be something
something like a set crdt where if a
join group and a leave group is in that
set when we aggregate those messages
together then we could say that oh you
know effectively if there's a leave that
must have meant that there was a joint
at some point and as a result we must
know that uh the join is invalid you
could also use version vectors for the
same point uh I'm not going too in depth
on this one because frankly I think it's
a bit of a tangent and I go into it a
little bit more in the last video
anyways so let's move on from that the
point is ultimately single leiter
replication is going to ensure that our
causal dependencies are consistent and
additionally it's probably not a
performance bottleneck for this table in
particular let's just use my SQL that is
basically going to be the same premise
for the next table that I'm going to
talk about which is the user database
obviously we're going to need a user's
database we have users and the fields
that we're basically going to need are a
user ID an email a password hash
something like that and of course
because there are a billion users this
is going to be a massive table we are
going to PR have to partition it let's
do so on the user ID this just makes it
easy assuming that we partition and
index on the user ID toine the data for
a given user we can just do something
like the hash
range and assuming that we have some
sort of consistent hashing schema that
we're following we can use a load
balancer to really quickly go to the
right partition for a given user and
fetch the data as we need it so again
even though this table will have a lot
of rows it's not going to have that many
reads to it and it's not going to have
that many wrs to it It All Things
Considered especially when compared to
our eventual chats table or messages
table and as a result of that again
let's stick to my SQL you might be
seeing a pattern here but the thing
that's going to break the pattern
eventually is going to be our messages
table so what's the One requirement that
I mentioned so far about our messages
table well it's that we do want to
eventually be able to load historic
messages because let's say I was signed
in on one device and then I open up a
second device and I want to see all of
my messages that I've sent sent in the
past on there and have been sent to me I
need to be able to quy this database so
this should ideally be fast so imagine
that we use the following schema we
could have some sort of chat ID and we
can Partition by this so that all of the
messages for a given chat are on the
same partition we can order by a
timestamp per message so that our
messages are presorted in the order that
we want to be viewing them in we can
have the message content and perhaps
some amount of metadata such as the
sender so keep in mind that because
because our messages are pre-sorted
because the messages are already on the
same partition ideally the query to
fetch historical messages for a chat
within a given time range should be
relatively fast now in particular I like
to compare my solutions to the grocking
the systems assigned Solutions and one
thing that they make a whole big deal of
is ensuring that all the devices either
see the same ordering or that all the
devices for a given user see the same
ordering but not necessarily across all
users in the group chat personally I
think you should just use this time
stamp field to maintain ordering that's
something that you can do on the front
end where you basically you know if we
were using react we would use a map
function to basically order by this
timestamp field the question is what
timestamp do we use do we use client
side timestamp do we use server side
timestamp I imagine that the server side
timestamp would probably be a bit more
consistent whereas a client side one you
know could potentially be fudged uh but
either way you know let's just go ahead
and get a time stamp in there even
though distributed timestamps are not
technically reliable able at the end of
the day this is a messaging app it
doesn't really matter if I send a
message a millisecond after you and it
looks like it came in first it doesn't
really kill anyone and so I think it
would be just fine to use a timestamp
let's be pragmatic that's the point of
being an
engineer so the question now is we have
our messages data format but what is the
actual database that we'd like to use
well this of course is going to
determine uh or rather be determined
based on what we want to optimize for so
for our table do we care more about
reads or do we care about rights well I
think it would be fair to say that we
would care about rights a little bit
more if all of our messages were first
being sent to a database and then after
we sent them to a a database we would do
some additional processing to them uh to
make sure that they got delivered to
every users's device at the same time if
this wasn't the case then perhaps we
could just fully optimize for reads so
what would we do if we wanted to
optimize for reads well our options
could be something like a b tree index
the reason that this is good is because
you know as opposed to reading from
multiple different SS tables we
basically just read from one place in
the sense that you know we Traverse a
tree and of course another thing that we
could potentially do is employ column
oriented storage so the question is how
would column oriented storage actually
help us here well it would be very
useful depending on the the size or the
amount of metadata submitted with every
single message so imagine that you know
the amount of the chat message that we
actually care about reading is say like
30% of the message and then 70% of the
bytes were metadata well then it would
actually be very useful to us to just
ditch that metadata only read the uh the
part that we actually care about and
then go ahead and show that on our
client devices on the other hand you
know if metadata was 10% column oriented
storage probably wouldn't really help us
that much but I think that it could
actually help us overall because at the
end of the day most of these big you
know social media sites are probably
including as much metadata as possible
with every single message they're doing
a lot of post processing on this type of
data for data analytics and at the end
of the day I could see it being useful
so for that reason I'm actually going to
deviate from my original messenger
design where I recommended Cassandra and
I'm going to agree with grocking the
systems design interview that we can
probably get away with using hbas keep
in mind though that hbas is not the
fastest solution for rights even though
it does use an LSM tree based
architecture which is nice in terms of
actually getting away with writing to
memory first before right gets flushed
out to dis the big downside of
it is that it uses single
liter
replication and so while it's true that
we can probably go ahead and partition
our table a lot and Achieve better write
throughput as a result of that it is
possible that maybe that still wouldn't
be good enough so perhaps what could we
do to actually write somewhere when we
make an initial message right such that
it is still relatively fast in terms of
uh performing that right well perhaps we
could actually first buffer every single
uh chat right by putting it in Kafka so
first we would hit some sort of
messaging service we could then throw
the message right over here into Kafka
which we can partition on our chat ID
then of course as I love to always do we
can put things into Flink the reason
being that Flink and just using Kafka in
general ensures that every message is
processed at least once so we can be
sure that none of these messages are
getting dropped uh this is because flank
will occasionally effectively checkpoint
its state over to something like S3
which is really nice and then from there
in Flink we can not only go ahead and
insert the message into our hbase
database which is again going to be
partitioned on chat ID but we can also
then send it to all the other devices
which care about it such as my
phone now keep in mind that uh the
question is even though Flink is going
to make sure to process every message at
least once it could be the case that uh
Flink is going to send that message more
than one time to hbase this can happen
because you know Flink can send the
message it can never hear back from hbas
because of some sort of network
partition and it can go down in the
meantime so when Flink then comes back
up it might send a duplicate message so
how can we avoid this happening well
what we can do is we can assign
something like an item potent key to
every single message and we can do that
right over here on the server so we give
the message a uu ID such that when Flank
goes ahead and replays it we can
actually change our data schema a little
bit so that instead of just being sorted
by both time or or rather just time in
our database we can sort the message by
time and uu ID so now we know that if we
see a message for a given chat with the
same Tim stamp and the same uu ID it
should get replaced should be simple
enough we would use something like an
upsert operation which basically means
insert or up update if present and this
is going to get the job done for us we
don't really have to worry about right
conflicts or anything because hbase is
single leader and we don't really have
to worry about our right throughput of
hbas as much because at the end of the
day everything is getting buffered by
Kafka so as long as it gets into that
log based message broker originally we
should be good to
go so the question now is when we
actually get a message and we get it
into our Flink node over here how can we
go ahead and get it over to the client
devices well basically the idea that
we're going to try and follow is this if
I'm a phone and I am running the
Messenger application ideally I want to
maintain as few active connections as
possible the reason being that every
single active connection is going to use
extra data and it's also going to use
extra battery life on my device so in an
ideal world every single phone that's
running the messenger app can just
maintain a single active connection and
that that is the idea that we're going
to try and pursue every single user is
going to maintain a connection with one
chat server and now the idea is that if
we have a group chat with just 10 users
then the chats at most have to be sent
to just 10 different places so now
imagine the following if we have our
Flink node and the Flink node keep in
mind from the last slide is receiving
our messages via Kafka right
here what the Flink node can also do is
receive change data capture or CDC
from our actual chat members table which
means that for a given group chat for
example chat one it's going to know that
user 2 and user 4 are a part of chat one
it can cach this locally the reason that
we cach this locally and use change data
capture as opposed to polling from the
database every single time is so that we
can make fewer Network calls over to the
database and can just cach the results
as we need them so keep in mind that we
now have basically a local cache of
every single uh user within a database
or rather within a group chat and so
once we have this we can then say for
every single user eye within the chat in
parallel we can hit some sort of load
balancer which is then going to send all
of these
messages to the server the chat server
that user 2 and user 4 are connected
to so now this might seem simple enough
I've kind of abstracted things away a
little bit I think the question if
you're kind of looking at this one might
be well how does our load balancer know
where everyone is connected to so that
ideally is going to be the next piece of
the puzzle so how does a user get
connected to a chat server in the first
place well basically we should probably
use some sort of load balancing method
perhaps consistent
hashing so you can see over here if we
have something like a zookeeper now keep
in mind this is a coordination service
it's strongly consistent the reason it
exists is so that we can make sure that
we have some sort of consistent hashing
ring that every single node in the
system agrees upon what we actually want
to do is take a user ID on any single
client device and then say hey for this
user ID we know some function that says
F of user
ID equals server
ID so that way by using this consistent
hashing function we can very quickly
figure out which server a user is going
to be connected to and we need to
connect to the server for two reasons
both for sending messages to that server
and also for receiving messages from
that same server so as long as the load
balancer is listening to zookeeper sorry
about that ambulance come on guy get out
of here and we're back so as long as the
load balancer is listening to zookeeper
which you can do it's fully a
functionality of Zookeeper that you can
actively listen to changes on it the
load balancer will know the function
which is the consistent hashing ring and
that way whenever a user says Hey I want
to connect somewhere it's going to point
to the load balancer and the load
balancer is going to redirect it to one
particular server so the nice thing
about load balancers as well is that you
don't just have to have one of them you
can actually scale these out if you
watch my load balancer video you'll know
that you can have these in an active
active configuration which basically
means that not only do we have one load
balancer but we can actually have
multiple different load balancers and
they're all going to be listening to
zookeeper so they'll all know the
consisten hashing
function so again the nice thing about
this is that all of those load balancers
are going to point every single user to
the same exact
place so when a user goes and starts up
it's going to first reach out to the
load balancer next the load balancer is
going to point it to a particular server
based on the load balancer uh function
for consistent hashing that it gets from
zookeeper number three is that the
server is now going to initiate some
sort of handshake
with the client and four the client is
going to respond and then we're good to
go actually we may have to switch the
order of three and four but the gist is
the client and server are now connected
directly to one another after first
going through the load balancer so the
question is well what if this guy goes
down right here well what we can do is
this guy can be sending occasional
heartbeats to both the client and to
zookeeper so when it goes down we can
configure our timeouts such that
zookeeper knows first and updates all of
our load balancers so now the load
balancer has the new consistent hashing
function and then eventually user 9 is
going to say wait a second I haven't
received a message in a minute hey load
balancer assign me to someone new and
the load balancer is now going to assign
it to something like S3 which is going
to again establish a handshake with our
client device and so now we're good to
go again so one important thing to note
is that we should make sure that if you
know there's user 9 and then over here
we've got user
10 and user 10 was also connected to S2
maybe this guy user n should time out
after something like uh 60
seconds and user 10 should time out
after something like 55
seconds the reason being that uh if user
9 and user 10 were to time out at the
same exact time we could potentially
cause a Thundering Herd you know if
we've got a million different devices
all trying to go through the load
balancer and they all get mapped to the
same different node then we may bring
down that server and that would be very
bad so it's important to have some sort
of random Jitter there so the question
is we know now that every single client
device is going to have some persistent
connection with a chat server so that it
can actually receive messages from there
the question is what actual real-time
connection protocol should we be using
well let's think about the properties
that we actually want within that
protocol for one we're going to send and
receive a a lot of messages and it would
be great if we didn't have to constantly
reestablish connections all the time
because when we do it means that every
single request has to send a bunch of
headers and metadata and that is going
to take up some space and make a request
slower so for that reason maybe we can
rule out long polling I'm not saying
it's infeasible it would just be a nice
optimization to be able to send less
data every time we send a message to the
chat server and every time we receive a
message from the chat server
additionally it would be pretty nice if
we had some amount of control over when
the actual client reconnects to the
server if a connection between a client
and server goes down we don't want it to
instantly reconnect because again we
could cause a Thundering Herd it would
be nice if we can establish some sort of
random Jitter so for that reason perhaps
maybe server sent events isn't the best
thing for us because it does do this
automatically at least to my knowledge
it's possible that one of you might look
at the docs prove me wrong and then I
look like an idiot but either way I
think that uh the biggest argument for
my ultimate Choice here is going to be
websockets and that is going to be that
we want by directional communication not
only are we sending messages to a chat
server but we're also receiving them it
would be nice if we could just have one
persisting connection it's going to keep
things as fast as possible and so it
seems to me that websockets is going to
be the technology that we want to go
with so with that all out of the way
hopefully I've covered everything in a
decent amount of detail and we can
actually get oursel to the final design
so here on our left we've got a client
so the client has a couple of things
that they can do for starters they can
always hit the user service and they can
always hit the metadata service and the
metadata service and the user service is
going to be responsible for both the
users table and the chat members table
which I mentioned are both probably not
going to be performance bottlenecks so
as long as we keep them as my SQL tables
and are just smart about how we're
actually partitioning those whether it's
on the user ID for the users table or
the chat ID for the chat members table
then we can go ahead and do an easy
enough job there there now actually
funny enough look who was being an idiot
was that I said that we should partition
on chat ID in the chat members table and
if you recall earlier I mentioned that
we should be partitioning on the user ID
which I stand by and uh I wrote this
down incorrectly so the point is we
should index on the user ID for both of
those so that we can quickly figure out
for a given user what chats they're
actually in that is going to be helpful
then from there in addition we need the
change data capture from the chat
members table but the main difference
that we're going to be doing is rather
than sharding this by user ID we're
actually going to Shard by chat ID so
that within a Flink node that's going to
be responsible for sending messages out
we actually know for a given chat ID
what users they have and that would look
something like chat
one has user two user 4 user six so
obviously we need to be able to know uh
what users are in which chat as result
okay the next step of this is the actual
handshake with the chat service so a
client would start up their device they
would open up the messenger app and the
first thing that would do is hit our
load balancers now keep in mind that
somewhere over here we would have like a
zookeeper which is responsible for that
consistent hashing function but the load
balancers in the active active
configuration will probably be going
ahead and caching that consistent
hashing ring and as a result they can
connect our client with one of the chat
servers let's say we connect with this
front guy right over here so from that
point the client is going to establish a
websocket connection with that chat
service so now if a message were to go
from uh Flink over back through the load
balancer and into the chat service it
could then go over to our client which
is going to be very useful for receiving
messages but let's first look at how
sending a message might look the client
would hit the websocket it would go
ahead and send a message to the chat
service the chat service would then
publish it over to Kafka down here the
messages themselves are all going to be
sharded on chat ID so that we can make
sure that the Flink node that receives
that message knows which users are in
the chat and so then when Flink receives
the message for chat one it's going to
say oh I see that I have to publish this
for user 2 user 4 and user 6 so then in
parallel what it can do is send a
request saying hey I have to contact
user two user 4 and user six all at one
time and that can go through the load
balancer now keep in mind that the load
balancers have the consistent hash
function cached locally and as a result
they can then send that message and
Route it to whichever one of the chat
Services they actually need to do this
chat service is going to be horizontally
scaled as you can see over here I've got
like three
instances and let's say we have to send
it to every single one of the instance
because each one is connected to user
two user 4 and user 6 and then once that
message comes in the chat service can
then look at its local websocket
connections and say oh shoot this is
going to one of the users I'm connected
to let's go ahead and send that back
over of course the last kind of piece of
the puzzle is actually being able to
read historic messages that is going to
also be uh imported from Flink such that
when Flink receives a message it's going
to reach out to the chats table which is
up here now the one thing to note about
the chats table is that I've kept that
as an hbase table the reason being that
column oriented storage is going to
allow our data model for chats to get
particularly beefy if we want to add a
lot of metadata while still keeping
reads pretty fast we can Partition by
chat ID to ensure that all messages for
a given chat can be fetched relatively
quickly and of course presort by both
time and uu ID the time for actually
sorting the messages on a client device
and the uid for ensuring item potence
when messages are published from flank
anyways guys I hope this design makes a
decent amount of sense this is not too
long of a video which is good and uh
that means that we didn't have to go too
crazy with deep diving uh this is again
kind of actually a similar design to
something like Twitter or to Google
Drive even where we're effectively using
change data capture to Route things to
the proper place but yeah hopefully
you're starting to see a pattern here
and uh as always if you have anything to
roast me about in the comments please do
I'm looking forward to it have a great
week guys and I will see you in the next
one